I'm working on a novel it is a story of
my life and my sisters make it short and
spicy and if the main character is a
girl
make sure she's married by the end so
first of all I wanted to ask you Timothy
Christian Bale I know you work with him
he's played Laurie in the 94 version and
I know he recently said that he is gonna
bring his daughter to see the movie
because she wants to see yes I want to
know if you did have a chance to talk to
him about playing three I know I know I
didn't good I haven't gotten the
opportunity to uh just yeah discuss
playing the same role but that really
that experience on hostels with him I
know it's new a little women so but uh
long story short that's one of our
greats
that is a great yeah that's a great man
he's a great man that's the way I look
up to I could have had I was gonna ask
you if there was another remake of a
Christian Bale movie that you could take
on that role what would be oh I don't
know he's Korean I'm not it's not bad
she's careers exceptional and they're
kind of unreached because he really
there's like you think about different
American Psycho is from Batman from
American hustle from what Americans
though I guess he you playing any of
those roles by the way you can't I can't
you can't really I mean yeah he's what a
formidable career yeah amazing um to you
I was just speaking with Tom Rahman the
chairman oh my god I said well he's a
fan of yours I said to him I said I'm
gonna be interviewing Greta like we'll
give me something give me something and
he said the first time that he met you
it was in the league of meeting
Spielberg's and knowing you were going
to be quote-unquote like a great
director and I said what was it I knew I
could make you cry no no it's it's an
amazing compliment and I said what was
it about her and he said the specificity
and there was I I read something about
the flower used in the movie oh can you
talk a little bit about that like how
specific that choice was well I'm first
of all I have to say like this making
this movie and getting
to make this movie with this caliber of
a cast shooting on location here in
Concord Massachusetts where the book was
written shooting on film getting to
really give it a huge canvas and the
scope that I think this book deserves
because it is one of our American
classics and as part of the literary
canon is so much down to Amy Pascal who
fought from yet every second of the way
and Tom Rothman for saying yes which was
a miracle no one makes movies like this
anymore and they certainly don't make
them on the scale and it was just
incredible to me that he'd put the
weight of Sony behind it yeah it's hard
to overstate how rare that is and I know
there was there was a scene in the movie
there was a watch that was a modern-day
watch that got that you were wearing and
then Greta picked up on it and said no
no no not quite a watch but that you
swapped clothing as well that users just
swapped clothing yeah and I was
wondering about that as a choice but
also if there can you do searches voice
if you're swapping clothing can you I
bet she could do she could do you yeah I
embarrass myself trying to and probably
offend a couple people but um yeah I
feel like anytime I've tried to do an
Irish accent in front of Saoirse it's
just yeah I think any like three words
ish but the swapping clothing because
they're like a favorite item of clothing
that you donned or was there was there
something that sort of was like oh this
this feels great
there were little Laroy there were
little trinkets that I liked and like a
about that were hers you know and that's
not pretentious but Moschino waistcoat
or I don't know that big wasting
whatever coat that could solve like yeah
yeah like that could have big buttons in
this costume designer her name is
Jacqueline Duran this she's an
incredible creative period and kind of
lives for the period and somewhere I
shouldn't say that period but lives for
I think non clothes are not dripping in
modernity and just quick I have just
like
yeah enough time for action um you said
in a QA and that I think you were
referring to the author but you said
that sometimes the future reaches
forward and pulls you yes can you sort
of talk about maybe how that worked for
you in this film did that happen for you
like when you watch in this movie oh
yeah yes I mean I I think that the
future spoke through Louisa May Alcott I
think that there's a straight line from
her to me I don't do what I do
unless she did what she did weekend
because she did that's just the truth
and I don't think the 20th century would
have been folded in the way that it was
with female creatives if she hadn't
written this so I mean did the future
speak through us I hope so I hope so in
that I hope that what this movie does is
is give it back to the viewer and say
what are you making what are you writing
what are you doing what are you moving
forward so I hope so but I guess and we
won't know until the 22nd century about
you I had that happened with you like
we're the future um you mean you passed
in future into the future a meeting like
this with they're sort of like a jump in
time of like seven years back and forth
in the movie so is there in a way how
have you changed in the seven years like
I when you look at yourself as an actor
of course is 15 same game playing very
director that's what you want too isn't
it Jo to be famous right yes but it
sounds so crass when she says
my girls have a way of getting into
mischief so do I so first of all this is
little women but I keep hearing on said
there were dirty jokes there was
wrestling there was like you guys were
just there was massing there was oh
there was knitting so that was the flip
side like a mutual right yeah
wrestling evz donut Friday you don't not
Friday and we were just talking about
her Laurie used to get us these juices
cause like most mornings we were getting
off at like 4:00 a.m. to start the day
because of the lack of light and stuff
and she would get these juices that were
like bright blue but they were natural
and they just gave us this kick at the
end of the day and we're always eating
Wendy's so Camaros and Wendy's it was
was anybody dipping into her fries how
do you be cool around her because that's
I interviewed her once and I
accidentally called her mirror instead
of Meryl so I know you you I think you
would said like the first take you were
just like hold on - hold on reset last
time I met her I she everybody knew that
she was upstairs in the in the green
room and she came down the stairs
wearing this big dress and I was dressed
as young Amy and as she came down the
stairs simply because obviously I
thought I feel like I know her because I
watched her my entire life I saw her
coming down the stairs when she was like
hello kind of in character and I have
never felt so embarrassed in my life
because I was like oh no I wanted to ask
you guys if this if we took your
characters and put you guys in modern J
and you guys all had a group text what
would that look like
I mean we do have many group texts yes
yeah we have like four on the go
whatever it is called big chicks one
called one's called Myra me actually
sorry didn't know how to use what haha
they had to teach me
very apropos dude alright like comes up
in she's like did you get my water we're
like no you never saw the movie you're
like I never got that no you were like
so did you get them it's fine if you
didn't write back no llores maybe you
were sending it to her us phone from
lost I might've who would be the best
sisters Beth cuz she's so much because I
feel like night but he's the woman that
kind of responds to invite her in like
two days or family okay and then I was
talking to Timothy about this and he
said that because I knew you had to swap
clothing right I had you guys swap
clothing a little bit just as we're
tried to wear his M thick silver chains
so he wears at basketball games but I
said can you swap voices can you do yeah
I asked him if you could do your voice
and he said that one of you could do
great Timothy sha'lame impression can
any of you do Timothy you didn't say hey
why don't you give it a go so he's like
he comes up to you and he'll like yeah
yeah like a whole sometimes yeah no no
you said this was a dream come true I
think you put it on your Instagram
yesterday so just for all of you just
this being such an incredible we're here
where louisa may alcott lived in road i
mean just a little talk a little bit
about that just it was a dream we lived
here from September to almost Christmas
in this amazing town and space going to
Walden Pond for walks learning about the
history of the place you know all of it
adding to the film but now we have the
gift of this memory in the film
- and we're forever family yeah even
when they don't hear from me while I've
been texting